in the midst of all the terrible things
that have been going on over the last
week we do have sort of what might be
considered good news maybe but it's
barely registering given what else is
going on a Republican congressman Devon
Nunez is stepping down as the head of
the house intelligence committees Russia
investigation this is something we've
been calling for and many others have
four weeks now nuñez is the former Trump
transition team member who's been known
to personally update Donald Trump on new
developments in the investigation yet
another person withdrawing in a long
list of shameful recusal zand
resignation surrounding Trump and Russia
Nunez made his announcement 26 minutes
before the House Ethics Committee
announced that it would be investigating
him for disclosing classified
information so just in time they're like
for example when he told the public that
Trump associates had been caught up in
surveillance of Russia or other foreign
powers with no other possible motive
than to try to vindicate Trump debunked
Obama wiretaps me claims noon has also
briefed Trump on the classified
information which just demonstrated how
close Nunez was to the president totally
unsuited to be leading an investigation
into the President and people have been
telling devin Nunez to step down for a
while now it seems like he's only doing
it because of the house ethics
investigation into him and Nunez is of
course blaming the ethics investigation
into left-wing activist groups that's
the perfect scapegoat anytime a right
winger is called out for doing something
wrong it's left-wing activist that
caused this entire thing to happen right
and I thought these investigations were
beyond party you know it's a good thing
that he's stepping down from this Trump
Russia probe but he should also just
step down as chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee because if he
can't be fair and impartial when the
entire country's watching it if there's
relatively minor cases how can we expect
him to be fair and impartial knows yeah
what's he doing in the investigations we
don't know about and congressman Adam
Schiff who's the house intelligence
committee's ranking Democrat said quote
it will allow us to have a fresh start
moving forward I actually don't agree i
think that the house russia
investigation as a result of now being
led by republican congress
and Mike Conaway is going to be just as
bogus we're talking about tom rooney &
trey Gowdy getting involved who led the
witch hunt around Benghazi it's a total
mess I think the investigation will be
slightly less bogus under those guys
like five percent less bogus yeah I mean
this is happening within the house and
the Senate and those are obviously
inherently political bodies yeah I would
like to think that the FBI investigation
will come out to be a lot more credible
there are House Democrats including some
on the committee who have said they feel
encouraged by the shift for example
Democratic congressman eric swalwell
said quote we now have a chance to
reclaim our committees independence
credibility and ability to make progress
maybe I mean the house Intel
investigation had become a total joke
like much of what's happened since
january twentieth or really since
november eighth in a lot of ways many
people are already forgetting about this
though which is exactly what Donald
Trump wants and it is exactly what I
predicted would happen if we had a sort
of national security related shock event
like what's happening in Syria these are
the perfect distractions Pat to the
entire Trump Russia thing and that's why
it's important we need to do two things
we need to cover all of the news that's
going on but we also can't forget about
the fact that there are multiple
investigations still happening in to
trump Russia we have to strike the
balance and I'm sure that Trump is quite
upset that his Lackey is now out of the
position as investigating him right yeah
although i don't know that these other
republicans are that much better at
least for now probably still trying to
stay on Donald Trump's good side but
we'll follow it will see whether that
investigation devolves into more of a
joke or becomes slightly more
professional there's a YouTube
advertiser boycott going on which means
ads are not playing on our YouTube
channel which means we're no longer
making any money from these videos
please help us fight back and replace
that revenue you can become a member at
david pakman.com slash membership if you
want to discount use the coupon code I
voted 17 we need your help